We the People of the United States in
order to form a more perfect union
establish justice next to the
Declaration of Independence the
Constitution is the most important
document in US history and secure the
blessings of liberty to ourselves and
our posterity do ordain and establish
this constitution for the United States
of America and effects each of us every
single day but today many of us are
unaware of how and why our freedom
depends on it
Hillsdale College America's uniquely
independent classical liberal arts
college is offering a free online course
Constitution one on one for a limited
time you actually have to study some
very fundamental things to learn the
meaning of America and the causes of its
constitution with over a half a million
already enrolled Constitution 101 is
available free for a limited time so
register today online or by calling the
number on your screen right now
you know fifty years ago and a hundred
years ago people trusted the government
and they felt they were in control of it
what has changed do you want to know you
can know at Hillsdale College every
student is required to complete a one
semester course on the Constitution to
graduate we want to make this American
experiment of self-government under rule
of law work then that requires a certain
type of citizen and again that's you and
that's me and that's why every single
American should care about the
Constitution if you understand the way
things are supposed to work you're not
you're not only hurting yourself but
you're hurting your fellow Americans so
register today online or by calling the
number on your screen right now it's
part of your duty as an American to
understand our Genesis understand the
creation of America and understand why
we do to say things like American
exceptionalism without the Constitution
and without a knowledge of the
Constitution we don't know what our
liberties are how they're secured or how
to perpetuate them it's gonna make you
feel different about being a citizen
United States pursue truth defend
Liberty don't wait register for realz
Dale colleges free online course today